David's answer was good, but not necessarily optimal. I think he put handle as
fixed at this particular place in the explanation because the first reason here.
He wanted to capture the notion, that only fixed-handle cups enable drinking.
And that this spot does it. He wanted to capture the notion that only
fixed-handle cups enable drinking and this scenario does that.
However, this not an optimal way of fixing this particular explanation. However,
this is not the best way of fixing this particular explanation because it leads
to additional decisions. It suggests that, only those things which have a fixed
handles are liftable, but of course, from the pail we know, that the pail
does not have a fixed handle and yet the pail is liftable. This suggests that
handle is fixed should go somewhere else. Perhaps above, object is liftable, but
still below object enables drinking. Agent two can figure out that this is
not the optimal case for putting case as handle as fixed. Because A,
it voided its notion of pail, a pail is liftable, but has a movable handle.
It also voided this notion of a briefcase. This part was coming from a person of
a briefcase. The briefcase with removable handle, and it to is liftable. This is
how the agent knows this handle is fixed should go somewhere else, in this
explanation. Above object is liftable, but beneath object is enables drinking.